(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
- My favorite part is
the lunch tray aspect.
- What's happening?
- Is that jalapeno cheddar sausage?
- I believe it is.
This is the regular sausage,
and then this is jalapeno.
Last time we talked
about Cooper's Barbecue.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Having trouble finding good
barbecue places out here.
So I was like, you know what,
my friends at Cooper's,
they were like, we gotta
get Kelly some barbecue.
- You just trump him.
You're my favorite guest.
Just kidding. (laughs)
- Mine too.
- He brought food.
- I did bring food-
- From Texas.
- But for everybody.
Yeah, they flew it out.
- This is from Texas?
Oh, my god.
- It's here.
- It looks really good.
- What's the protocol
on eating the food?
Like how-
- It's right now.
- I think it's we dig into these.
- Do I let y'all talk for
a little bit and then...
Okay, cool.
- Its for everybody.
- Cool, cool, cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool.
- Please.
- It's so good.
- I know.
- Oh my god, wait, you gotta
get the jalapeno cheddar.
- We got like brisket.
We got ribeye, we got sausage.
- I'll let you guys talk for
a little bit and I'll be...
- Oh.
That's my...
- Yeah, the sausage.
- That's my jam.
- Right?
Oh, my god.
- I know.
I wish I had enough for everybody.
Sorry.
- I know.
- This is from Coopers and this
is next door to Billy Bob's.
Is that where we were talking
about last time, right?
- Yes.
- I perform to Billy Bob's.
I never had this.
- Well, there's a first
time for everything.
Now you can go back.
- Oh, my gosh, it's so good.
God, I love that.
- This is tasty as...
- So wait, you're from St. Louis.
What's barbecue like there?
- St. Louis has great barbecue.
My brother is a barbecue artist.
He's got this huge egg
that can smoke for like 12 to 24 hours.
- Oh, my mouth is watering.
- And then just rib tips
falling off the bone.
But this is tasty, too.
So, you know, respect
to Texas, it's all good.
- Okay.
- All good.
- Healthy competition is good.
- Amen.
- That drives innovation, right?
- Absolutely.
- Y'all keep keep talkin'.